welcome to the David Pakman show I am
fair and cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today a lot of talk about right
all right Tuesday yesterday we had some
big primaries in several battleground
states across this country what are the
biggest ones however was my home state
here the state of Florida where we
actually put up as the Democratic
nominee now officially for governor of
the state of Florida
Andrew Gilliam who is the first as of
right now first african-american to ever
be a major party nominee for the
governorship in the state of Florida
that alone is a historic achievement not
to mention the fact that Gilliam had
actually raised and spent less money
than all of his Democratic rivals in
this primary add to that the fact that
he was the most progressive candidate
running for the Democratic side and you
come up with a pretty significant
victory Gilliam was endorsed by Bernie
Sanders he supports a medicare-for-all
he hundred percent supports impeachment
of Donald Trump even though that's not
something he would be able to do as
governor of Florida but in every way
possible this guy is a true progressive
and his victory was 100 percent historic
also on the Democratic side here in the
state of Florida and this is a big deal
Sean Shaw another African American I
believe he would also if he wins would
be the first african-american Attorney
General of the state of Florida so right
now we've got some diversity some
much-needed diversity on the ballot in
the state of Florida a state that has
been under consistent Republican rule
for decades now that says a lot about
what's happening down here in the state
of Florida and with these progressive
champions that have won their primaries
down here we also have a few heartbreaks
right Matt Gaetz the outspoken Trump
supporting congressman from Florida's
District one on fortune
where I sit everyday where I live
he won his primary he won his primary
handedly which means pretty much without
a doubt this man's getting re-elected to
Congress my district here district one
in Florida is a plus 22 Republican
district he's going up against a pretty
decent Democrat Zimmerman is her name
and you know I like her I'm gonna vote
for her because there's no other option
but unfortunately given the demographics
of this area gates is coming back he's
gonna continue to go on Fox News and any
other cable news show every opportunity
he gets he's gonna be an outspoken Trump
supporter still and he's gonna continue
to tell us that these are witch hunts
and that we need to be investigating
Hillary Clinton also on the negative
side down here in the state of Florida
is Rhonda scientist who has now become
the Republican nominee or the
governorship DeSantis in case you aren't
aware I'm gonna give you a little bit of
homework here you need to go look at
this ad De Santis ran where he takes his
infant child and essentially jokingly
indoctrinates them into trumpism tries
to get them say make America great again
the kids sitting there playing with
these big blocks he says build the wall
it is one of the creepiest and most
disgusting things you could imagine but
Florida's not the only news right okay
we had primaries over in Arizona another
contentious state you have the open
Senate seat the Republican nominee is
going to be martha mcsalley she beat out
Joe Arpaio but in order to do that she
who she was once considered a moderate
Democrat no Trump lover by any means at
one point she shifted her tongue she had
to move even further to the right in
order to beat Arpaio and the other
Republican challenger and she ended up
getting the endorsement from Donald
Trump so now we have a trump astre
publican running in Arizona that one is
not a given although it is still a
likely Republican seat one that the
Republicans
would hold on to however given what's
happened with the state of Arizona
specifically John McCain passing
recently the disrespect from the Trump
administration to McCain regardless of
what you think about McCain himself or
his legacy
it honestly it truly was disrespectful
what the White House did with regards to
McCain that may come into play in that
election so that's gonna be one to pay
attention to as the weeks roll forward
here's what got me though you had seen
him writing for CNN Chris Cilicia said
that here's the here's this headline
Donald Trump was the big winner Tuesday
night Donald Trump was the big winner
Tuesday night that is a headline CNN ran
you know the alleged network that Trump
says just hates him is filled with fake
news they declared him the winner
because two of his people two people he
liked won their nominations two people
he endorsed yeah that doesn't make him
the big winner especially when one of
the people you're obviously talking
about is from the state of Florida Ron
de santis when you completely ignore the
major victories of people like Andrew
Gilliam and Sean Shaw that was the story
Andrew Gilliam is the one who was
stealing headlines all around the
country Tuesday evening and solicit
still has the audacity to say Trump's
the big winner oh oh look what's coming
his way
no the folks in Florida stood up against
the old guard kind of democratic
establishment down here in the state
that continuously loses they picked the
most progressive candidate the one the
only one running by the way who was not
super wealthy
a few weeks ago the n-double a-c-p
actually held a democratic candidate
forum and Gilliam was the only one that
showed up the other Democratic nominees
couldn't be bothered to go to this
Gilliam was the only one to show up and
I hope that come November Gilliam is the
one that shows up in the Florida
governor's mansion that is what this
state needs as someone who has lived
here for my entire life I can tell you
Republican rule is absolutely destroying
this state maybe not to the extent that
we saw it in places like Kansas which
Kansas in Oklahoma also had primaries
yesterday those are states that the
Democrats are actually kind of hopeful
that they may be able to flip at least
the governorship of Oklahoma gonna be
tough there's a lot of races to keep
your eyes on it's difficult at this
point to even attempt to you know make a
prediction of what's going to happen
here what's going to happen there so all
we can base it on is what we have
already seen and what we're seeing not
just here in the state of Florida but
all over this country is that we are
seeing these alleged are left candidates
winning they're winning because they're
offering the people what they want to
see they're offering them policies that
benefit everyone and that is something
that people are not used to but it's
something that voters in this country
have been asking for for many many years
and finally looks like we're getting
some candidates out there who understand
that